uh RFK you're seeing vivec you're seeing
different names coming you know RFK is
now the conversations were you know
scheduled something fantastic by the way
so the question will be what are some
wild cards that we're not even Chris
Christie says in two weeks I'm going to
go in and I know Trump is afraid of
debating me all this but who are some
wild cards that nobody is thinking about
that could be potential stars in the
2024 or we pretty much already know who
it is no one else is going to get into
it yeah I think we know who it is you're
going to see people pop up because you
want to sell books uh I I wouldn't be
surprised if uh AOC Pops in I think it's
a very low probability for ocasio-cortez
but she's got she's famous enough is she
even 35 she will be yes and so she she
is eligible I'm pretty sure
um I'm pretty sure but uh uh I think we
know who it's going to be
um she's eligible by two weeks she's
going to be she'll be 35 uh October 13th
of uh two weeks before election so she's
33 right now actually I think it's uh
you have to be 35 before being
inaugurated which means if her birthday
was the day before inauguration I think
that would still keep her make her very
disappointed let's live in reality right
now for at least for now yeah I think
she's got 10 years
but still gonna evolve her
AOC is a start doesn't mean you have to
agree with me
yeah you're right and uh everyone
laughed at Trump and she is if you see
what will happen with an AOC is I think
the media will prop her up as a star
Democrat which which uh default liberals
they're described as would just vote for
she will capture the progressive left in
a way that no Democrat candidate can
yeah I mean come on Biden yeah dude
sleepy Joe is not going to cut it this
time around there's there's no pandemic
and to to keep people uh you know locked
up yeah and we uh me and Adam had a well
we still haven't bet on it because you
were in Vegas you should have done it we
bet that um besides Biden Gavin Newsom
would probably be the guy to slide in we
just had another conversation Tim I
don't want to say no names but this guy
looked at us and goes do not be
surprised if out of nowhere Michelle
Obama just goes you know what here I go
because she's denied denied denied which
one do you think is a more reasonable
like either uh Michelle or or Gavin
Gavin people think Gavin isn't going to
be the guy but you never know man and it
is relatively early but I I'm not so
convinced Michelle Obama would want to
do it but I do think there's a very
strong chance of winning however ask me
a year or two ago I probably would have
said Michelle Obama would win in a
landslide and I mean that figuratively
not literally I mean she'd win by like a
strong margin uh now I'm not so
convinced you know uh I like to hang out
at the the the the casinos on the
weekend play poker and I'm at MGM
National Harbor this is in West Virginia
it's a great Hotel MGM National Harbor
they just built it a few years ago it's
a beautiful location beautiful on the
water incredible in Maryland oh it's
gorgeous I just stayed there it's just
south of DC but it is Maryland yeah
beautiful little area this is this is DC
this is as blue as it gets yeah poker
table not a single person at that table
anything nice to say about Joe Biden or
Donald Trump but they all said I don't
know man I can't vote for Joe Biden and
that felt to me kind of like a
I don't want to say I'll vote for Trump
but I'm probably gonna vote for Trump if
he's the guy because there's a lot of
that going on let me give you another
name because you live in West Virginia
you might like them you might hate them
I don't know but I'm gonna throw this
out there I actually like your Senator
Joe manchin nobody likes him in West
Virginia but how does he keep getting
elected he's not gonna get it no no no
no no no no he's been elected the last
40 years he's devastated Tim
yeah he's whether or not he gets elected
for the 50th time he goes good
nightclubs we're in Joe manchinson 100
but he's been elected as a democrat in
the red estate in the country or one of
the Reddit states of the country
continually as a Democrat how does he do
it has he continued to do it I mean
whether he continues or not but he's
done it already the proof is in the
pudding firstly I'm in the Eastern
Panhandle which is an hour from DC 15
minutes from Frederick big cities and
it's it's like a it's like a moderate
area that leans right and then you get
into the core of West Virginia and it is
Maga country it's 86 I mean right the
people who live around me are all die
hard Trump uh because this country used
to be fairly moderate because Democrats
and you look at Joe manchin's politics
and he's fairly conservative in a lot of
ways yeah so back when he did run I mean
was it 2018 I think he got reelected
the the country was relatively different
and people were still willing to say
yeah Democrat Republican but now you
think we've changed that much dude Bud
Light I'm at the casino I'll punch you
right in the face right now Tim cast
there's an old guy and he's just like I
ain't drinking that and I'm like do you
even know why you're not drinking that
it's just the culture wars have become
so pronounced that's why I'm saying I
think Peter teal is wrong about DeSantis
the the hyperpolarization of this
country is is is the conversation
so I just think
I go to I go I'm hanging out West
Virginia there's not a single person I
have ever met who says they would vote
for Joe manchin you've got too many
great options you've got you've changed
I mean now right now okay got you two
things things have transformed that much
in the last four years yep that's
someone who's been a democrat in mansion
Maga country if Mansion switches parties
he might stand a chance
wow yeah nice but you've got uh Mooney
who I believe is running he's the he
represents West Virginia's first and the
the Trump people love him you have Jim
Justice the governor who's term limited
out and he's going to run for Senate and
well they've elected him you know to a
term limit so people seem to like him
I'm not gonna pretend to know enough uh
everything about Western Union politics
I've only been here for a couple years
but just my general understanding from
being there and talking to people we
actually just went to a dinner a
republican dinner uh this past weekend
no one there likes me not a single
person at anything nice and anything
nice to say about him so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]